[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
In today's video,
we are revisiting experiment
where we tried breaking
a vacuum chamber underwater.
We're going to do that again,
but with a few twists varieties
that should make it even cooler.
[Music]
Not too long ago, we had an
experiment where we learned
what would happen if you had
a vacuum inside a glass bottle,
and then shattered
that bottle underwater.
I thought that experiment
looked really cool,
and I said that I
wanted to revisit it,
maybe scaling it up.
There are some varieties
that I really want to try,
and this is because
I thought that looks so cool
that I needed more footage of it,
and so we now have
a flat walled aquarium,
and I've got eight different bottles,
and we're going to try
a few different things.
We're going to put
some stuff in the bottles
before we pull a vacuum,
then close them off,
and then break them underwater,
and see what happens.
Here's the basic idea.
A small piece of rubber will work
as a stopper over a glass bottle.
We'll pull all of the air out
of the bottle in a vacuum chamber.
We'll fill some of our bottles
with a variety of different materials,
and see how they look
when they break underwater,
especially in slow motion.
As a sort of comparison shot,
we'll start with a plain empty bottle
with a vacuum inside,
and see how that looks.
[Music]
Similar to last time,
we are going to start with one
miniature marshmallows in our jar,
and that's just to
give us a visual representation
of whether or not we've got
a good vacuum pulled in the glass.
As you probably know,
if there is a good vacuum,
that marshmallow will
be puffed up quite a bit.
[Music]
The marshmallow seems
to have stuck to the bottle
from a little bit
of residual moisture,
but it shouldn't affect anything.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
That's interesting.
It actually cracked the first time.
The glass was damaged
but holding itself together.
That's so weird.
Like you can feel everything
gets sucked in a little bit,
and it sounds just like...
[Music]
We tried putting one
marshmallow in the bottle.
Now, let's see what happens
if we fill it quite a bit.
The marshmallows will
expand in the vacuum.
So hopefully, they'll kind of fill
the whole bottle before it shatters.
[Music]
Some of the marshmallows down
near the bottom got big fast
enough that they sort of
plugged everything up,
so the lower marshmallows
don't have any space to expand.
You can see how big
the marshmallows at the top are.
Okay, we've got a jar of
partially inflated marshmallows,
because they inflated so much
that they started deflating again.
[Music]
It's cool to see this one in slow mo
because as I saw the result,
I wasn't quite sure how
all of the marshmallows
ended up in that one corner.
Next up, we're going to try
some neon blue food coloring.
We're just pour all
of it into the bottle,
and we'll see what happens
to it when we pull a vacuum.
But it's not going
to completely turn into gas,
so we should still have
really low pressure in there.
Let's find out.
[Music]
The super low pressure is
causing our food coloring to
start bubbling a little bit.
No, now, it's causing
it to bubble quite a bit.
Bubbling and splattering all over though.
It's kind of neat.
All right, I think that
means we're at a good vacuum.
Let's pressure back in.
Maximum effect.
I'm going to try and coat this
whole bottle in our food coloring.
Just looks like blue glass now.
[Music]
That's awesome!
That was really impressive watching how
fast and far that blue coloring spread.
It was almost instant
that the whole tank was blue.
Looking at it at super high
speed, of course, I can see
that it wasn't actually instant,
but it felt that way
when I was doing it.
[Music]
I really liked how the bottle
with the food coloring in it went,
so now, I want to try using
this super neon green ink.
[Music]
That's delightful.
It sinks instead of floating.
Is not as much floating.
[Music]
Not many things that I've
put in a vacuum chamber
have expanded more than whipped cream.
So now we're going to try
putting a little bit of that
in one of the bottles,
see what it does.
[Music]
I'm a healthy person.
Whipping cream in a vacuum bottle.
[Music]
I actually want to stop it
before it goes too far
because we have tested,
and you can unwhip cream
by pulling too much of a vacuum.
So, we're just going to
leave it nice and expanded.
[Music]
What might happen if we
have something in the bottle
that reacts with the water itself?
We're going to try using
a little bit of baking soda,
and a little bit of citric acid.
When they're both dry,
they aren't going to react,
but as soon as water hits them,
we should have quite a good fizz.
1, 2, 3.
[Music]
Because we're watching
it at such slow frame rate,
it's fun to see the glass shatters,
the water flies into the vacuum,
fills it up,
the bottom starts dropping off,
and then, kind of right
when you think like,
"Oh, it's over,"
that's when it starts reacting
with the chemicals inside the glass,
and you get a second burst of fizziness.
Now, in this bottle, we've got
five different colors of sand,
layered on top of one another.
The sand of course is just a powder,
and isn't going to react
in the vacuum chamber,
but I'm really hoping
we have like a cool spray.
Like when the water goes rushing
into that depressurized bottle,
it all just like fly in there,
and they'll have
colors going everywhere.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
That is some really fun footage.
I love watching those in slow motion.
I like we got several different results.
We had some of them where the
bottle got cracked all the way through.
We had somewhere just
cracked part of the way,
and we just had these fun explosions.
Water just flying around.
Colors, sand, whipped cream.
Overall, I really enjoy doing this.
If there's anything you would
like to see us try inside a vacuum bottle,
breaking it underwater,
let us know down in the comments.
Guys, that's not all there is.
We've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you should go check it out.
The box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you need to be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to the channel,
that way, you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.